来,我们来和大家聊一下怎么搭建系统这个事情
想到搭建系统这个事情的话呢,我先给大家分享一个词叫
做认真做好一线
小事
好
我给大家说几个长几个
第一个长几个
哈哈哈哈,对边有一个老婆姐,对边两啊,一个老婆姐说你休息会儿吧,跟不上了,不要就
你们还
你回头发的这个事情放出来,我陆起来,放的事情就直接放出来给大家分享一下
对
记住,如果你现在有工作
如果你现在有工作
请你不要讨厌你的工作
既然你现在已经做这个工作了,麻烦你回去干这么一件事
你看看在你的工作中,那些事是非常重要的
那些事是反复重複的,不断出现的
做一个事
首先找到那个
你一定要做
但是又大量的重複
你又繁索的不行
必须做你又不愿意做,还要每天还要做的这个事
有没有
有没有,有吧,有,麻烦你,你去做,别逃避
你把他要不然变成一套流程
要不然把他变成一套,魔法
什么批批戏魔法
什么会议流程
什么都能什么什么东西
能力?
只要是这样的东西,我再说一遍
我愿意做
又必须做
还要大量重複的做,把这个事
把他做成一套流程一套魔法,一套自动化可以完成的事
然后用我之前教你们的方法,还记得我真教你们的方法,卖颇到的方法还记得吗
把它放到网络上
还短是给你好写文案也好
看看,有没有人要
反复重複做这件事
你就会找到一个
能够让你
不再靠
肉体
赚钱的事
出卖时间出卖肉体赚钱的事
这是第一个,你有工作的情况下
如果你的工作不适合做,这不是合作的事,比如说是保密的事
麻烦你干这件事,每天至少抽出一个小时
周末
至少抽出八个小时,你周末有周六周日
每天抽出一二十
周末至少抽出一个事,你去给我找这样的一件事
认真去购练他,今天完成一点,明天完成一点,后天完成一点
比如说,什么批批模板,什么油键,模板,手机的背景的信息呀
怎么自动生成,怎么自动跟成文本写生成文章啊
怎么能够完成自学的模板呀,打卡去懂啊,都可以
请你从现在开始每天认真干一件事
一边干
一边把它暂时
比如的impopping,都可以听懂了吗,但是认真购练事
不认许给我去阅读,不认许给我去学习,不认许给我去上课
认真做一件事
软后,该学学,该上课上课
能懂吗
不认有说,我胡子哥,我这,我这两年我一直在学习,我一直在上课,你做不成事的,好吗,去做一件事
这个事需要支持,该去学学,该去语读,越多,越多,能力了,去做一个事
这个事对别人有帮助,别人有帮助,别人有帮助
Learning,连帮助,必须去跟我去做自媒体,管你是文章也好,还是断什么也好,你过去做
不要在乎留谅
只要有人问
和你要做这个事相关
你就阻动帮人解决,就像我一样阻动帮人解决
不要一上来就管人要钱,你掉到钱而已了,没见过钱吗
我发现好传
帮那个聘拉大事就管人要钱,记住不要要钱,刚开始就免费帮人做
你以为你在免费人家赞你便宜,你记清楚了,人家在帮你购点产品
各位听懂了吗
我记得我今天一直给大家讲说,我每天中间休息的时候,我会回答大家的问题
然后有人问问题,然后给大家回答好多人人呗,你这个过来一方不是的,你问的问题对我来说都是资产
因为你也问他也问他也问他也问他,这不是资产这啥
这么多人都问,什么你遇到这个问题,我记得觉得,这个钱不就赚到了嘛,这个时候不着急赚钱,把他做成产品给别人用
用的公众来的人越来越多,越来越多的时候
你就可以说一个很想的门口,这个钱不就周安了吗
这不就有你的覆电了吗,你就有个这么一个东西
这什么,这就是你从一个大工人卖肉气的,很难听,卖实际的人变成一个什么
变成一个不再需要靠卖实际上专前的人,这是第一步
第二步
你要从一个资源者变成一个配置者,啥意思,以前是提供时间,提供什么东西了,就要资源者
然后现在你要干的事情,这个事,人们已经喜欢了,你要把这个事资动换
规模换,可复之的话,这个弄理减了吗
我这个事已经有需求了,已经我是想了,你要把它做得更好的
成本更低,用乎更大,这叫资本的话,开始加尴尬了
开始规模换,开始资动换了
这个时候你会发现,当你做完了以后
那个东西,叫系统
懂了吗
好的人讲说胡子哥,你给我讲,怎么做系统,我要一伤来跟你讲,是你那叫胡说八道
系统矛痛
那叫系统,就是系统
PBT
那是讲,怎么做系统的PBT,有个聘用呢
系统不是这么讲的,系统是需要购建的
所以你要一点,一点,一点,一点做完了,就抽出来那个东西,那叫系统
我现在给你讲,怎么做系统
那个叫,我给大家讲,怎么做系统的PBT,你得到的是个PBT,好吗呢,不是系统
好,体会一下,我讲的这个东西是可以实骚的